cuál es la medida del ángulo y hace aquí
tenemos este símbolo que significa
ángulo y luego estas tres letras
c ahora para medir el ángulo hace lo
primero que necesitamos es encontrar el
ángulo que hace en la figura que tenemos
aquí y la forma en que lo podemos hacer
es usar las tres letras y las vamos a
revisar en el orden en el que nos las
dan la primera letra que tenemos es el
así que es la primera que tenemos que
encontrar acá
de ahí nos vamos a la segunda letra a
y finalmente nos vamos a la última letra
c en el orden en el que se nos dieron
así que esta abertura que tenemos aquí
es nuestro ángulo queremos saber cuántos
grados mide esta abertura la forma más
común de medir un ángulo es con un
transportador pero no tenemos un
transportador así que no lo podemos
hacer así pero tenemos suficiente
información en este diagrama para
resolverlo lo que podemos ver es que
nuestro ángulo
ac está compuesto por dos ángulos más
pequeños el primero es el ángulo e
y lo escribo de este lado ángulo y a b
más el ángulo de a c
el ángulo de hace
tiene dos ángulos uno es este de aquí
acá
y el otro es este
cuando los juntamos se forma un ángulo
del mismo tamaño que nuestro ángulo así
que si podemos combinar estos dos
ángulos sabremos la medida de nuestro
ángulo porque estos dos ángulos
combinados son iguales que nuestro
ángulo entero así que empecemos con el
ángulo y vemos qué mide 60 grados tiene
una abertura de 60 grados más el ángulo
de ac que tiene una abertura de 75
grados
y si los combinamos este que mide 60
grados más este otro que mide 75 grados
estamos cubriendo el ángulo entero que
estamos buscando la abertura que
necesitamos saber es 60 más 75
entonces podemos sumar esto para
encontrar la medida de nuestro ángulo
seis decenas más siete decenas es igual
a trece decenas o 130 13 y 10 al final
porque estamos hablando de decenas más
cero unidades más cinco unidades es
igual a cinco unidades 135 es igual a
135 grados así que la medida de nuestro
ángulo hace es 135 grados